Speaker 1: All right, let's go back to the
phones and hear from a few more people,
we take calls via Discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord. Let's go to Jordan
in Richmond, Virginia. Jordan, you're on the air.
Jordan in Richmond, please unmute yourself
so we can chat would love to hear from you.
And last opportunity for
Jordan, I see you're talking,
but you have muted yourself or your mic
isn't working, so we can't hear you.
All right, that's too bad. Jordan from Richmond
was really hoping that that would work. Let's
go to is it ISA from London? Is that right? Isa.
Speaker 7: Hey, David, how's it going, man? It's
going well. Um, yeah, I actually don't think that
you would choose me, so I guess I just wanted to
say thanks for covering the Rittenhouse trial. It
was pretty, pretty entertaining and informative as
well. You know, I honestly don't know much
about U.S. law, so I was learning as well.
And with your coverage and the coverage from
your fans, so um yeah, thanks. Thanks for
thanks for current that and my pleasure. It
was a real that judge was a real horror show.
Speaker 1: Why didn't you think
I would call on you? I'm curious.
Speaker 7: Because I don't know, I just this
is low, the people in the chat, so oh, OK.
Speaker 1: Yeah. All right now, tell me
which was the entire vigilante militia scene.
That was the context of the trial. Insane
to you as a person who's in London.
Speaker 7: Yeah, it was because, you know,
obviously we don't have guns or anything,
so the whole idea of especially a kid who is
underage at the time, just picking up some gun
from his armory and just running around playing
quality that that's just like you. You don't
you never hear of that. Like as an English person,
you will never hear of something like this in your
lifetime, ever. Yeah, that was that was crazy.
Speaker 1: That's interesting. So like for you,
is it even hard to say? Well, I guess
like so as you watched the trial,
were you most interested in the specific
defense or just the general context in
which all of this was taking place?
Speaker 7: You know, I was coming in,
I was interested in the whole thing, but as I
was watching the trial, I became more and more
interested in Kyle's defense. And I was, you
know, this might sound a bit controversial and
I'm not by saying this. I'm not saying that
I support Kyle in any way whatsoever. Yeah,
but I was honestly, I was drawn to his defense
lawyers and the way they worked, honestly,
because I think they they took full advantage
of the judge, you know, with the whole pixelated
video thing. Oh yeah. And, you know, asking for
a mistrial over and over again. I was just always
drawn to the way they were working, honestly.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I was definitely compelling
to see. No, no question about it. All right. Thank
you so much for your perspective. I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: It's still my call, David.
Speaker 1:
All right. Take care. There is ISA from London